yeah welcome to this video playing sv
mihailov with a norwegian flag that
seemed yeah i could come on let's play
the groom fault I really have I really
don't have a good recipe against to
gruene for this white so let's try this
black we are pulling went for the
absolute main line with thinking it's
not so popular nowadays not quite sure
why ok so this many moves here
b6 is the line that recently gained some
popularity also Knight e5 and e6 this
also Bishop Bishop d7 this kind of setup
Ellis's has been played a lot buyer by
Peter swidler who obviously is one of
the great greenford experts yet probably
of all time these some latest census
childhood days and continues to do so
which really shows that is very much
yeah believing in this in this opening
yeah many ideas I could could try Knight
e5 tending to to use the Seaforths coil
maybe not so familiar of so familiar
with them with the opening he can hear
ya all the time has got the opportunity
to take on c5 but it would relieve and
now now sir as a possible on let's say
I'm a moment wed might make some sense
because if we can be six but the ideas
after taking very often to play be five
and grab those vital squares deform and
perform especially the night only two is
a is a very poor piece and this set up
so should I play in the eyes maybe maybe
Bishop a four actually
maybe Bishop a form yeah why not can
play Bishop c2
interesting you should close the door
sorry for that i have them the not quite
sure what the name for this for this
machine is an English this thing that
drives your clothes after you have
washed it washed them before alright so
I'm but it makes a bit of a background
sound yeah he took a while for the
smooth which really looked like the only
move anyway but I understand he says
he's got this issue with the sea for
scrap let's see I could take and take a
night see fire but this looks good she
falls really a nice square of course he
he has the idea a possible idea to use
the B file but I'm not quite sure what
what he how he should use this I can
yeah if it had taken this bill should be
seven so but f6 is not not bad anyway so
I could take her take this or I could
try to to prepare bishop fa to c5 also
would be nice okay I can do that first
anyway
93 giada's rugby to twitch not really
helps okay just take it yeah at the
enter I I have fun really nice enter
Damien I'm controlling the D file and he
cannot really play rook be one attacking
me seven because of my day three can I
can't give a good check here but this is
this is nice push up to a three I don't
think I really want to control the
default
many many interesting ideas Bishop e3
how to tell what's the best one okay I
can further improve it's also a little
bit bit down on time so this Bishop on F
H this really needs some improvement now
you cannot play monkey one exchange on
everything okay check exchange
everything I'd like check in the shack
to win the porn so on check now this
this is very nice this end game i also
have after ship it's the porn but also
bishop check check Bishop c5 24 and then
the pawns are rolling even on their own
check
should I just advanced jazz probably the
easiest king important game sir is
winning easily he needs the clicking a
tube
not quite sure what he's doing I mean it
needs to play this move anyway okay ya
know I can also go here not rush things
this is this is also a way to go if he
takes a go etho I need to to get the
night away from d3 so that my kin kin
king can advance
30 seconds that's the only real issue
but it's plenty of time I'm simply not
that quick i mean the player like and I
camera really great online blitz player
would really wonder any kind of issue
with having service 30 seconds here
Chang no but is not not really playing
quickly yeah this is made made on with a
Jew quite resigned yeah I hadn't had an
excellent position here here I think
this is this is nice maybe the computer
disagrees it wants to play see phone
yeah right here maybe what is still
still okay I don't really think what is
better but what he played I think
immediately needs to to excellent play
for black let's check it quickly he
played rock deewani probably overlooked
this entirely yeah
the computer is giving a very funny line
rookie one look c 5 i'm sorry Roxy 5
because this traps the Queen in an
absolutely amazing way it doesn't have
any squares very funny but um I didn't
see that I mean I just thought that this
is this a good pieces and I can try to
to get to the c5 point later and what
you play Bishop c2 i think immediately
needs to an excellent game here why this
is clearly worse you can even debate if
i have played this in the best possible
way yeah but here this is almost lost
Whitey's got the week's big pause this
is simply an excellent piece on c5 and
yeah I have many ideas this one
additionally or just exchanging this
yeah this look nice thanks for watching